Tenemos una simple lista de verificación para esto.
De hecho, ya conocen el primer elemento de esa lista de verificación.
Es aumentar la observabilidad,
para asegurarse de que las personas se enteren de buenas obras.
Sé que algunos de Uds. probablemente están pensando,
no hay manera de que la gente aquí piense,
"Oh, bueno, ahora que logro crédito por mi buena acción,
ahora vale totalmente la pena".
Y tienen razón.
Por lo general, la gente no lo hace.
Más bien, cuando toman decisiones en privado,
se preocupan de sus propios problemas,
sobre qué poner en la mesa para la cena o cómo pagar sus facturas a tiempo.
Pero, cuando hacemos sus decisiones más observables,
comienzan a atender más a la oportunidad de hacer el bien.
En otras palabras, lo qué tiene de poderoso nuestro enfoque
es que podría activar el deseo existente en la gente de hacer el bien,
aquí, para ayudar a prevenir un apagón.
Volvamos a la observabilidad.
Quiero darles otro ejemplo.
Este es de una colaboración.
con una organización sin ánimo de lucro que busca que se vote,
y lo hace enviando cientos de miles de cartas en cada elección
para recordarle a la gente y tratar de motivarlas para que voten.
Les sugerimos agregar la siguiente oración:
"Alguien puede llamarlo para conocer su experiencia en las urnas".
Esta oración lo hace sentir más observable cuando va a las urnas,
y aumentó el efecto de la carta en un 50 %.
Hacer que la carta sea más efectiva reduce el costo de lograr un voto adicional
de USD 70 a unos 40.
La observabilidad se ha usado para cosas
como hacer que se done sangre con más frecuencia
al enumerar los nombres de los donantes en boletines locales,
o para pagar impuestos a tiempo
al enumerar los nombres de los delincuentes en un sitio web público.
(Risas)
¿Qué pasa con este ejemplo?
Toyota consiguió que cientos de miles compraran un automóvil más eficiente
haciendo el Prius tan único...
(Risas)
que su buena acción se observaba desde más de un km de distancia.
Bien, entonces la observancia es genial,
pero todos sabemos, todos hemos visto
la gente camina por la oportunidad de hacer el bien.
Verán a alguien pidiendo dinero en la acera.
y sacarán sus teléfonos y se verán muy ocupados,
o irán al museo y pasarán indiferentes por la caja de donaciones.
Imaginen que es la temporada de vacaciones.
y van al supermercado, y hay un voluntario del Ejército de Salvación,
haciendo sonar su campana.
Hace unos años, investigadores en San Diego.
se unieron a un capítulo local del Ejército de Salvación
para intentar encontrar formas de aumentar las donaciones.
Encontraron algo gracioso.
Cuando el voluntario se paró frente a una sola puerta,
la gente lo evitaba saliendo por la otra puerta.
¿Por qué?
Porque siempre pueden decir: "Oh, no vi al voluntario".
o "Quería algo de allí".
o, "Ahí es donde está mi auto".
En otras palabras, hay muchas excusas.
Y eso nos lleva al segundo elemento de nuestra lista de verificación:
eliminar las excusas.
En el caso del Ejército de Salvación,
eliminar excusas solo significaba pararse frente a ambas puertas,
y efectivamente, cuando hicieron esto,
las donaciones aumentaron.
Pero fue entonces cuando las cosas se pusieron algo graciosas.
incluso más.
Los investigadores estaban en el estacionamiento,
y contando a la gente que entraba y salía de la tienda,
notaron que cuando los voluntarios se pararon frente a ambas puertas,
la gente dejó de salir de la tienda.
(Risas)
Obviamente, estaban sorprendidos por esto, así que decidieron estudiarlo más a fondo,
Descubrieron que había una tercera puerta de servicios públicos más pequeña.
que se usada para sacar el reciclaje...
(Risas)
y ahora la gente salía por esa puerta para evitar a los voluntarios.
Esto nos enseña una lección importante.
Cuando intentamos eliminar las excusas, tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos,
Porque las personas son realmente creativas en hacerlas.
(Risas)
Quiero cambiar a una configuración
en la que las excusas pueden tener consecuencias mortales.
¿Si les dijera que la enfermedad infecciosa más mortal del mundo
tiene cura, de hecho, que la ha tenido por 70 años,
una buena, una que funciona casi siempre?
Es increíble, pero es verdad.
La enfermedad es la tuberculosis.
Infecta a unos 10 millones de personas al año
y mata a casi dos millones de ellos.
Al igual que el programa de prevención de apagones, tenemos la solución.
El problema es la gente.
La gente necesita tomar su medicación.
para que se cure,
y para que no enfermen a otras personas.
Desde hace unos años, colaboramos con un emprendimiento
de salud por móvil llamada Keheala
para apoyar a pacientes con tuberculosis al someterse a tratamiento.
Hay que entender, el tratamiento de la tuberculosis, es muy difícil.
Estamos hablando de tomar un antibiótico muy fuerte
todos los días durante seis meses o más.
Ese antibiótico es tan fuerte que te hará sentir enfermo.
te hará sentir náuseas y mareos.
Hará que tu orina tome colores extraños.
También es un problema porque tienes que volver a la clínica.
cada semana para conseguir más pastillas,
y en el África subsahariana u otros lugares donde la TB es común,
ahora hablarás de ir a algún lugar bastante lejos,
teniendo transporte público duro y lento,
tal vez la clínica sea ineficiente.
Ahora estás hablando de tomar medio día libre del trabajo cada semana
de un trabajo que desesperadamente no puedes permitirte perder.
Es aún peor cuando se considera el hecho de que hay un estigma terrible,
y desesperadamente no quieres que la gente descubra que tienes la enfermedad.
Unas de las historias más difíciles que oímos son de mujeres.
que, en estos lugares donde la violencia doméstica puede ser algo común,
nos dicen que tienen que ocultarle a sus esposos
que van a venir a la clínica.
Así que no es extraño que las personas no completen el tratamiento.
¿Puede nuestro enfoque realmente ayudarlos?
¿Realmente podemos conseguir que lo sigan?
Sí.
Todos los días, enviamos mensajes de texto a los pacientes
para recordarles tomar sus medicamentos,
pero si nos detenemos allí,
habría muchas excusas.
"Bueno, no vi el texto".
O, "Sabes, vi el texto, pero luego lo olvidé por completo,
bajé el teléfono y me olvidé de eso".
O, "Le presté el teléfono a mi mamá".
Tenemos que eliminar estas excusas.
Y lo hacemos pidiendo a los pacientes.
iniciar sesión y verificar que han tomado sus medicamentos.
Si no ingresan, les enviamos otro mensaje.
Si no ingresan, les enviamos un mensaje nuevamente.
Si, después de tres veces, todavía no se han verificado,
notificamos a un equipo apoyo
y ese equipo los llamará y les enviará un mensaje
para tratar de volver a ponerlos en el carro.
No hay excusas.
Nuestro enfoque, que, es cierto, utiliza todo tipo de técnicas de comportamiento,
incluyendo, como probablemente habrán notado, observabilidad,
Fue muy efectivo.
Pacientes sin acceso a nuestra plataforma.
fueron tres veces más propensos a no completar el tratamiento.
Bien,
has aumentado la observabilidad,
has eliminado las excusas,
pero todavía hay una tercera cosa de la que debes estar consciente.
Si has estado en Washington, DC o Japón o Londres,
saben que los usuarios del metro allí
tendrán mucho cuidado de pararse en el lado derecho de la escalera mecánica.
para que la gente pueda pasar por la izquierda.
Pero, por desgracia, no en todas partes es que la norma,
y hay muchos lugares donde puedes pararte en ambos lados
y bloquear la escalera mecánica.
Obviamente, es mejor para los demás.
cuando nos paramos a la derecha y dejemos pasar,
pero solo se espera que lo hagamos en algunos lugares.
Este es un fenómeno general.
A veces se espera que hagamos el bien.
y a veces no,
y significa que las personas son muy sensibles a las señales
de que se espera que hagan el bien en una situación particular,
lo que nos lleva al tercer y último elemento de nuestra lista de verificación:
comunicar expectativas,
decirle a la gente:
"Haz la buena obra en este momento".
Una manera simple de comunicar las expectativas;
simplemente dígales: "Oye, todos los demás están haciendo la buena acción".
La empresa Opower envía a las personas en su factura eléctrica
un pequeño inserto que compara su consumo energético
con el de personas con viviendas de tamaño similar.
Y cuando la gente descubre que sus vecinos están usando menos electricidad,
empiezan a consumir menos.
El mismo enfoque,
se ha usado para que la gente vote o done a organizaciones benéficas.
O incluso reutilice sus toallas en hoteles.
¿Qué hay de este?
Aquí hay otra manera de comunicar expectativas;
simplemente diciendo: "Haz la buena acción" justo en el momento adecuado.
¿Qué hay de este?
Este recordatorio replantea
el tipo de tarea mundana de apagar las luces
y en cambio lo convierte en un aporte ambiental.
La conclusión es, muchas maneras diferentes de hacer esto,
muchas formas de comunicar expectativas.
Simplemente no se olviden de hacerlo.
Y eso es.
Es nuestra lista de verificación.
Uds. están trabajando en problemas con importantes consecuencias sociales,
y a veces es posible que necesite motivar a las personas para que hagan más bien.
Las herramientas que aprendieron hoy pueden ayudarlos con eso.
Y estas herramientas, no requieren que recauden fondos adicionales
o que desarrollen más tecnologías de lujo.
Solo requieren el aprovechamiento de la reputación,
incrementar la observabilidad, eliminar las excusas
y comunicar expectativas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)